Hi guys, listen I have 2500 videos okay
on YouTube
2500 so sometimes when you go to the
channel it's hard to find where to start
because it's all random so I wanted to
create a beginners video the basics so
if you're new to my channel if you have
friends and family members that are new
to my program this is the first video to
watch okay so let me just kind of break
it down and make it really really fast
keto or ketosis what does keto mean when
you burn fat your fat breaks down into
these things called ketones your body
can then use those as fuel okay so your
body can actually run on ketones it's a
much much better fuel source than sugar
fuel that most people run on it's
cleaner fuel it creates a lot of other
benefits which I get into in other
videos okay so keto basically means
you're burning fat okay
healthy keto is a version of regular
ketosis but with a twist a principle
that I use is you don't lose weight and
get healthy you have to get healthy
first to then lose weight so getting
healthy basically means in relationship
to eating providing all of your
nutrients okay so you're eating foods
that are high-quality that provide all
the nutrients so you get the
requirements that our bodies need so
what I recommend is something called
healthy ketosis all right so that's the
version the other action that I
recommend is something called IF what
is that
that's intermittent fasting what is that
that is a it's not a diet it's a pattern
of eating and not eating so instead of
doing three meals or six meals a day or
snacks in between the meals you're
eating less frequently why because every
time you eat you raise a hormone insulin
too much insulin is very dangerous in
the body so what we're trying to do with
healthy ketosis and intermittent fasting is
reduce the
excess of insulin we're not trying to
make it down to zero we're just trying
to get rid of the excess the vast
majority of the population has excess
insulin but they've never been tested
the doctors usually don't test it
they're focusing on your blood sugars or
blood glucose but not fasting insulin
okay I have videos on that but just oh
you can watch another video but the
point is that we're trying to lower
insulin so to do that you need to eat
less frequently let's say you start with
three meals per day with no snacks and
then you go to two meals a day no snacks
and that would be considered intermittent
fasting and some people do one meal a
day but the point is that it's just
eating less frequent it's not
necessarily focused on lowering calories
even though you will be consuming less
calories that focus is not on calories
it's about eating less frequently at the
end of the day we want to provide all
the nutrients so we need a certain
amount of calories the cool thing about
intermittent fasting is that because
you're eating less frequent the
requirements from nutrients go down
because the body starts being
conservative with its nutrients it
starts holding or retaining more
nutrients so what you would need for
three meals a day okay as far as
nutrients you would need less nutrients
for two meals a day just because the
body adapts sometimes people are
concerned about losing muscle mass well
the other cool thing is that when you're
doing intermittent fasting certain hormones
like growth hormone increases
dramatically to protect the muscles from
being lost okay so your body tends to
now conserve protein as well when you do
intermittent fasting so you're not going
to lose muscle mass so the two main
things that help you lower insulin are
the reduction of carbohydrates I'm
talking about the sugar refined carbs
the grains the pasta the cereal the
biscuits the waffles the juice the
alcohol I have a lot of videos on this
right here like a ton but that just kind
of gives you the summary and also number
two eating less frequently what we're
doing when we actually drop
carbs and we eat less frequently is
where adapting to fat-burning you're
actually making a new cellular machinery
to run your body on fat fuel okay and no
longer on sugar now what happens when
you consume too many carbs the insulin
comes in and takes it out and converts
it to fat so a lot of the fat on your
body right now has come from the
carbohydrates not necessarily the fat
that you ate but the carbohydrates that
you ate the other thing that people
don't realize is this in the presence of
too much insulin you can't lose this fat
so if you have a stubborn metabolism and
you can't lose weight we know you have
too much insulin is there a quick test
to know if you have too much insulin yes
just look down right now and if you
could see your belly you have too much
insulin because these are the main
symptoms of high insulin belly fat high
blood pressure high cholesterol fatigue
especially after eating decrease
cognitive function lack of focus poor
memory Moody irritable sometimes
depressed grouchy because the blood
sugar issue cravings for carbs for sure
and you're hungry all the time
especially between meals when you get
your body in the fat burning and now
your body is burning fat between meals
because before it wasn't it was
dependent on your diet and dietary sugar
so now when you're burning your own fat
wow you get rid of the hunger okay
you're not hungry anymore it makes it
easy to do this you don't crave anymore
that's why healthy keto and intermittent
fasting is very successful long-term
because it allows you to stick to it
because you're not hungry all the time
you're not craving sometimes when you
look up keto you'll see this little pie
chart thing right here it'll say 20%
protein maybe 70% or 65% fat as far as
the total calories 5% carbs okay this is
very confusing for people because you
have to calculate calories into grams
and this and that
this is the simplicity right here if you
just envision your plate, okay this is
your plate half of the plate should be
salad or vegetables okay a quarter of the
plate should be protein and the other
quarter should be fat
so this 65 or 70 percent fat which seems
like a lot of fat now remember one gram
of fat is more than twice the calories
of carbs and protein so this is
misleading in reality the volume of fat
is really only you know a quarter of
your plate and and lot of this fat is
actually mixed with the protein so it's
not as much as you think and then we
have the small amount of carbs out here
just to keep it really really simple
okay and healthy keto and intermittent
fasting is not just about weight loss
it's about getting you super healthy for
reducing inflammation for helping your
cognitive function helping your overall
mood making the body work better okay so
now that you have the basics now you can
go to the rest of the videos thanks for